l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement la parole est à madame
nicole ameline
merci monsieur le président ma question
monsieur le président s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
premier ministre je m'exprime au nom des
femmes qui se battent partout dans le
monde pour leur liberté trop souvent
pour leur vie et pour leurs droits
la gravité d'ailleurs de cette question
interdite me semble-t-il toute polémique
de kaboul à jaca elle résiste avec
courage à l'extrémisme et en turquie à
la régression de leur droit au moment
même où un projet de loi autorisant
l'auteur d'un viol à échapper à la
justice en épousant sa victime est à
l'étude
la france doit réaffirmer partout dans
le monde son attachement au respect des
droits fondamentaux des femmes
c'est notre responsabilité
singulièrement dans les pays affectés
par les conflits ou les crises et pour
cela nous avons un devoir être
exemplaire dans la mise en oeuvre être
exemplaire dans la mise en oeuvre
concrète de nos lois sur l'égalité
ce n'est pas le cas le chômage massif
aux racines et dans notre pays prive
trop de femmes de l'autonomie
professionnelle qui est la clé de leur
liberté la précarité en france a un
visage celui d'une femme et nous ne
pouvons pas reparler au reste du monde
si nous n'obtenons pas de progrès réel
sur ce terrain or les statistiques
disponibles ne sont pas révélatrices de
l'affaiblissement des conditions de vie
des femmes notamment des familles
monoparentales
au nom de mon groupe monsieur le premier
ministre je vous demande de réfléchir à
la constitution d'une mission
d'évaluation sur les indicateurs qui
sont aujourd'hui insuffisamment précis
ou fiable dans la connaissance de ce
sujet particulièrement grave en second
lieu mesurer la précarisation de la
situation des femmes que nous signale
toutes les associations que je salue n'a
de sens que si des solutions puissantes
et adaptés sont adoptés je pense en
particulier à une véritable offensive en
matière professionnelle n'est pas normal
aujourd'hui que sur des sujets aussi
innovant par exemple que le numérique
qui va changer le monde merci la part le
cas de madame laurence rossignol
ministre dé famille de l'enfance et des
droits des femmes
monsieur le président madame la députée
nicole ameline je suis heureuse de vous
entendre évoquer le respect des droits
fondamentaux des femmes dans le monde
c'est d'ailleurs dans cet esprit que
j'ai l'année dernière à l'onu demandé la
dépénalisation de l'ibg de l'avortement
sur toute la planète pour les femmes car
le droit à l'avortement fait bien partie
de droits fondamentaux des femmes
vous nous demandez vous nous demandez un
bilan en ce qui concerne la politique
que nous menons faveur de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes se
veulent ce bilan nous le faisons tous
les jours je vais vous donner deux
éléments le premier c'est les moyens le
deuxième c'est la volonté politique les
moyens nous les avons donné le budget
des droits des femmes augmenté de 50% au
cours de ce quinquennat augmentation
inédite dans l'histoire de la vème
république
en ce qui concerne la volonté politique
nous l'avons dans tous les domaines
égalité professionnelle ou là ou dans
les entreprises il y avait auparavant de
nombreuses entreprises qui échappait à
leur obligation de faire des plans
d'égalité
grâce à un habile dosage entre les
avertissements et les sanctions
aujourd'hui ce sont 70 % des entreprises
de plus de 1000 salariés et 30 % des
entreprises de plus de 50 salariés qui
aujourd'hui on dépend d'égalité la
parité en politique par exemple quand
nous sommes arrivés en 2012 il y avait
11 % de femmes conseillère
départementale
il en a aujourd'hui 50 % grâce à la loi
sur le binôme aux élections
départementales qui n'a pas été voté par
la totalité de cet hémicycle
enfin en ce qui concerne les violences
faites aux femmes demain je présenterai
le nouveau plan sur les violences faites
aux femmes
d'ores et déjà je peux vous dire que
nous avons créé 1600 places
d'hébergement pour les femmes victimes
de violence et que 300 mille
professionnels ont été formés
enfin comme l'égalité des droits des
femmes ce ne sont pas simplement des
intentions ce sont des actes la semaine
prochaine ici vous aurez examiner une
proposition de loi concernant
l'extension délit d' entrave à
l'information sur libé g et j'espère
qu'à cet instant
ensemble nous voterons cette proposition
doit merci